[Música]
hoy se cumple un año del primer
confinamiento en francia por cuenta de
la pandemia el 17 de marzo 2020 francia
entró en estado de guerra contra el cob
y 19 según lo anunció el presidente
manuel macrón ahora el gobierno se
prepara para imponer nuevas medidas
restrictivas en la región parisina la
más afectada por una tercera oleada de
contagios
en atlanta eeuu al menos 8 personas la
mayoría de ascendencia asiática fueron
asesinadas en una serie de tiroteos los
ataques tuvieron lugar en tres salones
de masajes y el presunto responsable un
hombre de 21 años ya fue detenido se
investigan los motivos de este hecho
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden pidió a los migrantes no intentar
entrar ilegalmente a eeuu mientras
crecen las críticas republicanas por el
aumento de la llegada de personas a la
frontera con mexico incluidos miles de
menores de edad que viajan sin
acompañantes la oposición denunció una
crisis humanitaria en la frontera sur
tras el desmantelamiento de las
políticas migratorias impulsadas por
forma
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 cerrado blanco un
gusto se cumple un año desde que entrará
en vigor el primer gran confinamiento en
francia un día antes el presidente de
manera macro le declaraba la guerra al
coronavirus un año más tarde el país se
enfrenta a una tercera oleada de
contagios y en la región de parís las
unidades de cuidados intensivos se
encuentran al límite motivo por el cual
el primer ministro anunció que llegarán
nuevas medidas restrictivas
justo un día antes del aniversario del
primer confinamiento por ccoo y 19 en
francia llegaron difíciles noticias para
los residentes de la región de parís un
tercer cierre está oficialmente sobre la
mesa
estamos en una situación crítica y
preocupante
me parece que de hecho es hora de
considerar nuevas medidas para la gran
región de parís población fácil y los
comentarios del primer ministro se
produjeron pocas horas después de que
confirmara que francia había entrado en
una tercera ola de la pandemia
caracterizada en gran parte por un
aumento de variantes más contagiosas y
mortales pero este sombrío panorama no
se detiene ahí con 419 casos por cada
100.000 residentes por semana en la
región de parís también ha cruzado el
umbral de la tasa de infección de 400
que había fijado el primer ministro hace
unos días el aumento de las infecciones
ha llevado de las instalaciones de salud
de la región al borde del colapso las
unidades de cuidados intensivos de la
capital y sus alrededores están casi
repletas
lo que obliga al estado a trasladar a
los pacientes a otros hospitales del
país hay tantos pacientes en
rehabilitación hoy como en el pico de la
segunda ola estamos en una fase de
aceleración ha llegado el momento de
poner en marcha más medidas para que no
acabemos diciendo que no a los pacientes
que necesitan tratamiento para cáncer o
cuidados cardiovasculares ya se han
implementado cierres de fin de semana en
dunkerque niza y el paso de khaled el
presidente manuel macro señaló que
quería evitar el confinamiento a toda
costa pero a medida que parís se
enfrenta a un aumento en los casos la
perspectiva de un cierre regional parece
cada vez más probable
y seguimos en francia porque dos semanas
después de haber sido confirmado un año
de cárcel el ex presidente francés
nicolas sarkozy vuelve ante los
tribunales esta vez por el llamado caso
pigmalión por la presunta financiación
ilegal de su campaña presidencial de
2012 sin embargo lo más probable es que
el juicio se ha aplazado nuestra
periodista en parís erika olavarría nos
recuerda este proceso esta vez nicolas
sarkozy comparece en el llamado caso
pigmalión ese es el nombre que tenía la
agencia de comunicación que organizaba
los actos de su campaña para la
reelección en el año 2012 pero esta
empresa gastó mucho más dinero del
permitido en la ley de partidos
políticos y para esconderlo tenía una
suerte de contabilidad paralela a través
de la cual emitía facturas falsas que no
iban a nombre de la campaña sino que a
nombre del partido del presidente en esa
época la mp nicolas sarkozy por lo tanto
juzgado por financiamiento ilegal de
campaña se expone un año de cárcel ya
una multa de 3.750 euros el ex
presidente en todo momento dice que no
conocía esta contabilidad paralela pero
que sí sabía
gastando mucho dinero en su campaña hay
que decir que nicolas sarkozy comparece
además con varios miembros de miembros
del que fuera su partido la ump y con
varios dirigentes de la empresa
pigmalión es muy probable que la
audiencia de hoy se suspenda ya que dos
abogados de los acusados están enfermos
de kobe 19
y vamos ahora a eeuu donde ocho personas
entre ellas seis mujeres de ascendencia
asiática fueron asesinadas en una serie
de tiroteos registrados en tres salones
de masajes de la ciudad de atlanta en
georgia un sospechoso fue detenido por
las autoridades nos amplía matías a
rayas
nuevo incidente de violencia armada en
eeuu un sospechoso de 21 años fue
detenido en el suroeste del estado de
georgia unas horas después de
registrarse varios tiroteos en atlanta
el sospechoso fue identificado como
robert around long de 21 años quien vive
en el condado de cherokee pero
actualmente está bajo custodia en el
comando de clips y nos hemos estado
comunicando con él lo pusieron bajo
custodia por lo que se sin incidentes
los ataques comenzaron alrededor de las
5 de la tarde en un primer spa del
condado de cherokee donde cuatro
personas fallecieron y siguieron en
otros dos salones cercanos dejando otras
cuatro víctimas seis de ellas son de
ascendencia asiática lo que alimenta la
teoría de crímenes raciales no se
descarta nada estamos llevando a cabo
una investigación de homicidio múltiple
así que donde nos lleven las pruebas ahí
es donde irán los investigadores los
motivos del ataque múltiple aún son
desconocidos sin embargo los asesinatos
se produjeron en medio de una reciente
ola de ataques contra estadounidenses de
origen asiático que coincidió con la
propagación del coronavirus en el país
y seguimos en eeuu o porque enfrenta una
nueva crisis migratoria la frontera sur
del país se está viendo desbordada por
la llegada masiva de miles de migrantes
muchos de ellos menores sin acompañantes
el presidente hizo un llamado para que
no busquen entrar ilegalmente a eeuu
desde su llegada a la casa blanca el 20
de enero
las detenciones de migrantes se han
disparado poniendo de nuevo el tema
migratorio en el centro del debate
político del país
alva santana con el informe
huyen de la pobreza y el hambre pero al
alcanzar la frontera con eeuu las
expectativas de los migrantes en busca
de una vida mejor no se cumplen
alentados por las políticas progresistas
del presidente yo bailé en los
desplazados se topan con la realidad más
de 100.000 detenciones o expulsiones en
la frontera mexicana sólo en febrero
nosotros nos cruzaron por la frontera de
reynosa cuando llegamos ahí pues nos
tomaron
[Música]
y después no ingresaron mañana al cuarto
donde están todos
y jamás nunca nos preguntaron más
a dónde íbamos quién nos recibía y a
otras que estaban allí se vayan a
madrugar nos sacan y nos suben a un bus
luego nos llevan al aeropuerto y nos
suben a un avión y nos tiraron a carpas
atrás y ya de ahí el paso tenderán a
tirar hasta el puente de quads
especialmente el flujo de niños que
viajan sólo se ha disparado ellos son
los únicos en los que no expulsan del
país como bailén prometió a su llegada a
los menores son sometidos a exámenes
médicos hasta que encuentran acogida
aunque muchos tienen familiares en eeuu
la crisis ha obligado al demócrata a
desplegar a la agencia federal de manejo
de emergencias para atender a los niños
son cerca de 4000 los que se encuentran
en las oficinas de aduanas cuando llegan
los grupos casi la mitad o hasta la
mitad son niños
estamos hablando de
en líneas de 86 años hacia abajo niños y
niñas
que
que vienen acompañados desde o con sus
padres o algunos de sus padres la
situación de los migrantes amenaza con
empañar una de las principales promesas
de campaña de vaivén aplicar una
política migratoria más progresista
continuamos en la americana donde una
ciudadana de ese país dio a luz a un
bebé que según expertos sería el primero
en nacer con anticuerpos contra el cob
en 19 su madre una trabajadora de la
salud recibió su primera dosis de
moderna en enero a las 36 semanas de
embarazo los médicos presentaron sus
hallazgos pero éstos aún deben ser
analizados por pares para analizar este
tema saludamos en este momento al doctor
javier neto pediatra infectólogo doctor
buen día gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés y 4d preguntó qué
tan significativo es el nacimiento de
este bebé y si implica que las futuras
generaciones podrían gozar de una mayor
protección contra este virus
buenos días raúl gracias por la
oportunidad este es un caso anecdótico
considerando que no se vacuna actual las
mujeres embarazadas en este caso esta
era una trabajadora de la salud en
riesgo y por tanto recibió la vacuna y
como se ha visto con otras vacunas como
por ejemplo contra la tos ferina y
contra la influenza que son vacunas que
pueden ser administradas en las etapas
finales del embarazo y se ha podido
identificar anticuerpos transferidos de
la madre a estos niños así se ha podido
identificar anticuerpos de la vacuna de
que fueron anticuerpos generados en la
madre y transferidos a través de la
placenta a estos a estos niños y por
supuesto esto es lo que se conoce como
inmunización materna y de alguna u otra
forma hay un periodo de vulnerabilidad
de los niños donde
estos niños pueden ser susceptibles por
ejemplo a la tos ferina oa la influenza
y en este caso al alzar codos y esa
transferencia de anticuerpos podría
asegurar que estos niños estuvieran
protegidos al menos los primeros tres
meses de vida ahora vuelvo y repito este
ha sido un caso puntual y anecdótico y
esto necesita ser evaluado con más
detenimiento ahora doctor cree que este
caso sienta un precedente para
considerar la vacunación en el último
trimestre de embarazo de las mujeres en
este momento eso es poco probable tome
en cuenta que la agencia europea de
medicamentos y el comité de expertos de
la organización mundial de la salud y la
administración de alimentos y drogas de
los eeuu han sido muy enfáticos en que
no hay data dura no hay información
robusta que permite asegurar el perfil
de seguridad de las vacunas contra la
cob y en las mujeres embarazadas y de
hecho aquellas mujeres embarazadas que
reciben la vacuna son aquellas que
en algún riesgo de contagios como por
ejemplo estamentos de seguridad y
trabajadoras de la salud que sabemos que
están expuestas a la atención de
pacientes con lakovic y en esos casos
estas mujeres pues tienen una
conversación con sus coste tras se
analizan los beneficios versus los
riesgos de la vacunación y son ellas las
que deciden vacunarse pero sin duda este
estudio es un llamado de atención para
hacer estudios más formales en este
grupo de la población que son las
mujeres embarazadas así es doctor
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés y cuatro que tengo
usted es un feliz resto de día nosotros
continuamos con más información en el
estudio y continuamos con nuestra serie
de los jóvenes sirios en el exilio ahora
que se cumplieron diez años de la guerra
en ese país hoy conoceremos la historia
de suleimán alza acá y su familia un
símbolo de integración de los sirios en
alemania pero que también han sido
blanco de ataques por parte de la
extrema derecha
me llamo suleimán alza k tengo 23 años
vengo de homs en cydia y ahora vivo en
berlín forfait en berlin
sulaimán y su familia lograron
refugiarse en alemania en 2014 después
de perderlo todo huyendo de la guerra
lograron reconstruir sus vidas y
abrieron una pastelería siria en la
capital alemana sulaimán trabaja allí
varios días a la semana
antes de llegar a berlín ya teníamos eso
por objetivo y aunque en ningún caso
queríamos ser una carga para los
alemanes o vivir de los subsidios de
desempleo
ahora que son dueños de tres pastelerías
se hicieron un lugar en berlín pero ese
éxito también los ha hecho blanco de la
extrema derecha en repetidas ocasiones
aquí pintaron el símbolo de la ss y aquí
incendiaron una camioneta que
estacionada frente a la pastelería el
café
ataques que dejaron una huella profunda
en sulaimán
antes de venir pensábamos que alemania
era un paraíso luego nos encantamos un
poco aunque aquí estamos bien
pero uno pensaría de verdad que después
de la segunda guerra mundial este tipo
de cosas ya no existen según parece no
todos los alemanes cambiaron
a pesar de esta experiencia sulaimán
aspira a quedarse en alemania está
estudiando fisioterapia a distancia por
causa del cobi pero sueña con regresar a
homes cuando se termine la guerra
mi objetivo es algún día poder regresar
a siria para abrir un consultorio de
fisioterapia
me gustaría ayudar a la gente sobre todo
a aquellos que sufren de heridas de
guerra
mientras suleimán espera a partir de
este verano encontrar un puesto de
fisioterapeuta en berlín y seguir
apoyando a la empresa familiar
y ojalá lo logré hasta que el
informativo de france 24 continue con
nosotros para más actualización de
noticias
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2020 un millón más de
hogares nos ven en perú con esto en
américa latina' más de 93 millones de
hogares reciben nuestras